SIGNIFICANT BITE.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THE
PRESIDENT HAS LAID OUT CLEARLY
FOR WEEKS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT IS STEPPING UP
NOW.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> TODAY I'D LIKE PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THE CRISIS INVOLVING
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
I'VE BEEN CLEAR AND CONSISTENT.
THE UNITED STATES IS PREPARED,
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ARE READY WITH DIPLOMACY.
WE ARE READY TO RESPOND
DECISIVELY FOR RUSSIAN ATTACK ON
UKRAINE WHICH IS POSSIBILITY.
ALL THE EVENTS OF THE LAST FEW
WEEKS AND MONTHS, THIS HAS BEEN
OUR APPROACH AND REMAINS OUR
APPROACH NOW.
TODAY, I WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND, THE
STEPS WE HAVE TAKEN, THE ACTIONS
WE'RE PREPARED TO TAKE AND WHAT
THE AT STAKE FOR US AND THE
WORLD AND HOW THIS MAY IMPACT ON
US HERE AT HOME.
FOR WEEKS NOW, TOGETHER WITH OUR
ALLIES AND PARTNERS, OUR
ADMINISTRATION HAS ENGAGED IN
NON-STOP DIPLOMACY.
THIS WEEK I SPOKE WITH PRESIDENT
PUTIN TO MAKE CLEAR WE ARE READY
TO KEEP PURSUING HIGH LEVEL
DIPLOMACY, TO REACH WRITTEN
UNDERSTANDINGS IF THAT'S HIS
WISH.
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND I GRI THAT
OUR TEAM SHOULD CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE TOWARD THIS END ALONG
WITH OUR EUROPEAN ALLIES AND
PARTNERS.
YESTERDAY, THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT PUBLIC PROPOSE TO
CONTINUE THE DIPLOMACY.
I AGREE.
WE SHOULD GIVE THE DIPLOMACY
EVERY CHANCE TO SUCCEED.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE REAL WAYS TO
ADDRESS OUR RESPECTIVE SECURITY
CONCERNS.
UNITED STATES IS PUT ON THE
TABLE CONCRETE IDEAS TO
ESTABLISH SECURITY ENVIRONMENT
IN EUROPE.
WE'RE PROPOSING NEW ARMS CONTROL
MEASURES, NEW TRANSPARENCY
MEASURE, NEW STRATEGIC STABILITY
MEASURES.
THESE APPLY TO ALL PARTY, NATO
AND RUSSIA ALIKE.
WE'RE WILLING TO MAKE PRACTICAL
RESULT ORIENTED STEPS THAT CAN
ADVANCE OUR COMMON SECURITY.
WE WILL NOT SACRIFICE BASIC
PRINCIPLES, THOUGH.
NATIONS HAVE A RIGHT TO
SOVEREIGNTY AND TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
THEY HAVE THE FREEDOM TO SET
THEIR OWN COURSE AND CHOOSE WITH
WHOM THEY WILL ASSOCIATE.
THAT STILL LEAVES PLENTY OF ROOM
FOR DIPLOMACY AND DEESCALATION.
THAT'S THE BEST WAY FORWARD FOR
ALL PARTIES, IN OUR VIEW.
WE WILL CONTINUE OUR DIPLOMATIC
EFFORT AND CLOSE CONSULTATION
WITH OUR ALLIES AND PARTNERS.
AS LONG AS THERE'S HOPE OF
DIPLOMATIC RESOLUTION THAT
PREVENTS THE USE FORCE AND
AVOIDS HUMAN SUFFERING THAT
FOLLOW, WE WILL PURSUE IT.
THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE MINISTRY
REPORTED TODAY THAT SOME
MILITARY UNITS ARE LEAVING THEIR
POSITIONS NEAR UKRAINE.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD BUT WE HAVE
NOT YET VERIFIED THAT.
WE HAVE NOT YET VERIFIED THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY UNITS ARE
RETURNING TO THEIR HOME BASES.
INDEED, OUR ANALYST INDICATE
THEY REMAIN VERY MUCH IN A
THREATENING POSITION AND THE
FACT REMAINS RIGHT NOW RUSSIA
HAS MORE THAN 150,000 TROOPS IN
CIRCLING UKRAINE AND BELARUS AND
ALONG UKRAINE'S BORDER.
INVASION REMAINS DISTINCTLY
POSSIBLE.
THAT'S WHY I'VE ASKED SEVERAL
TIMES THAT ALL AMERICANS IN
UKRAINE LEAVE NOW BEFORE ITS TOO
LATE TO LEAVE SAFELY.
IT'S WHY WE HAVE TEMPORARILY
RELOCATED OUR EMBASSY FROM KYIV
TO WESTERN UKRAINE.
WE HAVE BEEN TRANSPARENT WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ABOUT
RUSSIA'S PLANS AND THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE SITUATION SO
EVERY ONE CAN SEE FOR THEMSELVES
WHAT IS IS HAPPENING.
WE HAVE SHARED WHAT WE KNOW AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING ABOUT IT.
LET ME BE EQUALLY CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE NOT DOING.
THE UNITED STATES AND NATO ARE
NOT A THREAT TO RUSSIA.
UKRAINE IS NOT THREATENING
RUSSIA.
NEITHER THE U.S. OR NATO HAVE
MISSILES IN UKRAINE.
WE DO NOT HAVE PLANS TO PUT THEM
THERE.
WE'RE NOT TARGETING PEOPLE OF
RUSSIA.
WE DO NOT SEEK TO DESTABILIZE
TO THE CITIZENS OF RUSSIA, YOU
ARE NOT OUR ENEMY.
I DO NOT BELIEVE YOU WANT A
BLOODY, DESTRUCTIVE WAR AGAINST
UKRAINE.
A COUNTRY AND A PEOPLE WITH WHOM
YOU SHARE SUCH DEEP TIES OF
FAMILY, HISTORY AND CULTURE.
77 YEARS AGO OUR PEOPLE FOUGHT
AND SACRIFICED SIDE BY SIDE TO
END THE WORST WAR IN HISTORY.
WORLD WAR II WAS A WAR OF
NECESSITY BUT IF RUSSIA ATTACKS
UKRAINE, IT WILL BE A WAR OF
CHOICE OR A WAR WITHOUT CAUSE OR
REASON.
I SAY THESE THINGS NOT TO
PROVOKE BUT TO SPEAK THE TRUTH
BECAUSE THE TRUTH MATTERS.
ACCOUNTABILITY MATTERS.
IF RUSSIA DOES INVADE IN THE
DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD, THE HUMAN
COST FOR UKRAINE WILL BE
IMMENSE.
THE STRATEGIC COST FOR RUSSIA
WILL ALSO BE IMMENSE.
IF RUSSIA ATTACKS UKRAINE, IT
WILL BE MET WITH OVERWHELMING
INTERNATIONAL CONDEMNATION.
THE WORLD WILL NOT FORGET THAT
RUSSIA CHOSE NEEDLESS DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION.
INVADING UKRAINE WILL PROVE TO
BE A SELF-INFLICTED WOUND.
THE UNITED STATES, OUR ALLIES
AND PARTNERS WILL RESPOND
DECISIVELY.
THE WEST IS UNITED AND
GALVANIZED.
TODAY, OUR NATO ALIES AND THE
ALLIANCES UNIFIED AND DETERMINED
AS IT'S EVER BEEN.
THE SOURCE OF OUR UNBREAKABLE
STRENGTH CONTINUES TO BE POWER,
RESILIENCE AND UNIVERSAL APPEAL
OF OUR SHARED DEMOCRATIC VALUES
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT MORE THAN
JUST RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
IT'S ABOUT STANDING FOR WHAT WE
BELIEVE IN FOR THE FEATURE WE
WANT FOR OUR WORLD.
FOR LIBERTY, THE RIGHT OF
COUNTRIES TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN
DESTINY AND THE RIGHT OF PEOPLE
TO DETERMINE THEIR OWN FUTURES.
FOR THE PRINCIPLE THAT A COUNTRY
CAN'T CHANGE ITS NEIGHBORS
BORDERS BY FORCE.
THAT'S OUR VISION.
TO THAT END I'M CONFIDENT THAT
VISION, THAT FREEDOM WILL
PREVAIL.
IF RUSSIA PROCEEDS, WE WILL
RALLY THE WORLD WHO OPPOSE ITS
AGGRESSION.
THE UNITED STATES AND OUR ALLIES
AND PARTNERS AROUND THE WORLD
ARE READY TO IMPOSE POWERFUL
SANCTIONS ON EXPORT CONTROLS
INCLUDING ACTIONS THAT DID NOT,
WE DID NOT PURSUE WHEN RUSSIA
INVADED CRIMEA IN EASTERN
UKRAINE IN 2014.
WE PUT INTENSE PRESSURE ON THEIR
LARGEST AND MOST SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND KEY
INDUSTRIES.
THESE MEASURES ARE READY TO GO
AS SOON AS AND IF RUSSIA MOVES.
WE'LL IMPOSE LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES, UNDERMINE RUSSIAS
ABILITY TO COMPETE ECONOMICALLY
AND WHEN IT COMES TO NORDSTREAM
TWO, THE PIPELINE THAT WILL
BRING NATURAL GAS FROM RUSSIA TO
GERMANY, IF RUSSIA FURTHER
INVADES UKRAINE, IT WILL NOT
HAPPEN.
I WILL NOT SEND AMERICAN
SERVICEMEN TO FIGHT IN UKRAINE,
WE HAVE SUPPLIED UKRAINIAN
MILITARY WITH EQUIPMENT TO HELP
THEM DEFEND THEMSELVES.
WE PROVIDED TRAINING AND ADVICE
AND INTELLIGENCE FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE, AND MAKE NO MISTAKE,
THE UNITED STATES WILL DEFEND
EVERY INCH OF NATO TERRITORY
WITH THE FULL FORCE OF AMERICAN
POWER.
AN ATTACK AGAINST ONE NATO
COUNTRY IS AN ATTACK AGAINST ALL
OF US.
THE UNITED STATES COMMITMENT TO
ARTICLE FIVE IS SACRASANCT.
I'VE SENT ADDITIONAL U.S. FORCES
TO BOLSTER NATO'S EASTERN FLANK.
SEVERAL OF OUR ALLIES WILL ADD
FORCES AND CAPABILITY.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO CONDUCT
CONDUCT MILITARY EXERCISES TO
ENHANCE DEFENSIVE READINESS.
IF RUSSIA INVADES, WE'LL TAKE
FURTHER STEPS TO REENFORCE OUR
PRESENCE IN NATO.
REASSURE OUR ALLIES AND DETER
FURTHER AGGRESSION.
TO BE CLEAR, IF RUSIA DECIDES
TO INVADE THAT WILL ALSO HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AT HOME.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT DEFENDING DEMOCRACY AND
LIBERTY IS NEVER WITHOUT COST.
THIS IS A CAUSE THAT UNITED
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
I WANT TO THANK THE LEADERS AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS OF BOTH
PARTIES WHO FORCEFULLY SPOKE OUT
IN DEFENSE OF OUR MOST BASIC,
MOST BIPARTISAN, MOST AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES.
I WILL NOT PRETEND THIS WILL BE
PAINLESS.
IT WOULD BE IMPACT ON OUR ENERGY
PRICES.
WE ARE TAKING ACTIVE STEPS TO
ALLEVIATE THE PRESSURE ON OUR
OWN ENERGY MARKETS AND OFFSET
RAISING PRICES.
WE'RE COORDINATING WITH MAJOR
ENERGY CONSUMERS AND PRODUCERS.
WE'RE PREPARED TO DEPLOY ALL THE
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL TO PROVIDE
RELIEF AT THE GAS PUMP.
I'LL WORK WITH CONGRESS TO HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS AND ADDRESS
THE PRICES AT THE PUMP.
WE'RE NOT SEEK DIRECT
CONFRONTATION WITH RUSSIA.
I'VE BEEN CLEAR THAT IF RUSSIA
TARGETS AMERICANS IN UKRAINE, WE
WILL RESPOND FORCEFULLY.
IF RUSSIA ATTACKS THE UNITED
STATES OR OUR ALLIES LIKE
DISRUPTSIVE CYBER ATTACKS
AGAINST OUR COMPANY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE, WE'RE PREPARED
TO RESPOND.
WE'RE MOVING IN LOCK STEP WITH
OUR NATO ALLIES AND PARTNERS TO
DEEPEN AGAINST THREATS IN CYBER
SPACE.
TWO PATHS ARE OPEN FOR SAKE OF
HISTORIC RESPONSIBILITY, RUSSIA
AND UNITED STATES SHARE FOR
GLOBAL STABILITY, FOR THE SAKE
OF OUR COMMON FUTURE TO CHOOSE
DIPLOMACY BUT LET THERE BE NO
DOUBT, IF RUSSIA COMMITS THIS
BREACH BY INVAING UKRAINE,
RESPONSIBLE NATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD WILL NOT HESITATE TO
RESPOND.
WE DO NOT STAND FOR FREEDO